Growing up is hard to do no matter who you
are but to have a camera capturing all of
those unforgiving pubescent years, it can
be downright tragic.
Some child actors are adorable children who
are unable to maintain that same quality as
they age.
Others are ugly duckling who became scorching
hot swans.
Here are 10 Nerdy Child Actors Who Grew up
to be Super-Hot.
Joseph Gordon-Levitt
Joseph Gordon Levitt has been acting since
he was a young child in films like Angels
in the Outfield.
He went through his awkward adolescence on
television with his role as the wisest yet
most hormonal alien on 3rd Rock from the Sun.
He was certainly showing his potential for
hotness as the adorable and endearing Cameron
opposite Larisa Oleynik in 1999’s 10 Things
I Hate about You, but it wasn’t until his
roles in independent films The Lookout and
Uncertainty that showed audiences his sexy
side.
After that, he melted hearts in 500 Days of
Summer, showed off some killer calf muscle
in Premium Rush and even made a Jersey mook
seem hot in Don Jon.
His company, HitRecord, not only helps others
come together to make art but also provides
the perfect excuse for him to show off his
musical talent and skills on the dance floor.
Lacey Chabert
When Lacey Chabert was on Party of Five, her
character Claudia was just the annoying little
sister.
With her chipmunk cheeks and squeaky high
pitched voice, it was hard to imagine that
she would grow up to be comparably hot as
her older Party of Five Co-stars Neve Campbell
and Jennifer Love Hewitt.
2004’s Mean Girls certainly proved that
all she needed was some growing up and maybe
a brighter and more form fitting wardrobe.
Chabert has maintained a productive career
in television and film.
While her looks have surely helped her, she
uses that voice of hers for a lot of animated
shows and video games and even played Meg
in the first season of Family Guy.
Nicholas Hoult
Nicholas Hoult was a cute kid in the 2002
charmer, About a Boy.
His toothy grin and thick accent won over
Hugh Grant’s obnoxious cad but also won
over audiences.
While he may have been sweet, it was pretty
unexpected that he grew up as good looking
as he did.
It was his role in X-Men First Class as Hank
McCoy AKA Beast that showed that puberty is
sometimes very kind to people.
After X-Men, Hoult kept popping up in films
like Warm Bodies and Dark Places continuing
to be insanely attractive even when it wasn’t
exactly a requirement for the role.
Who would have thought his role as Nux in
Mad Max: Fury Road would still make him appealing?
The man is a beast indeed.
Michelle Trachtenberg
Michelle Trachtenberg has been acting since
she was a youngster making rounds in Nickelodeon's
shows, The Adventures of Pete and Pete and
Clarissa Explains it all.
Nickelodeon liked her enough to give her the
starring role in their first feature film,
Harriet the Spy.
Her big blue eyes and awkwardly oversized
lips were covered by a mop of hair.
She went on to play Buffy’s annoying little
sister on the three final seasons of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer, but it wasn’t until
2004’s Eurotrip that Trachtenberg emerged
as a hot adult.
The CW’s Gossip Girl showcased her beauty
and seductive qualities as the meddling Georgina
Sparks.
Her usual look of silky dark locks, smoky
eyes, and slight smirk highlight just how
far she has come since being a gawky child
spy.
Matthew Lewis
Matthew Lewis may be the poster child for
nerdy child actors who grew up to be hot.
The British actor is best known as Neville
Longbottom in the Harry Potter films.
Attending Hogwarts for a decade must have
been good to him.
Lewis went from being a chubby tween with
buck teeth to being an attractive guy who
regularly shows off his athletic body.
Lewis is one of the more shocking transformations.
He went from looking like a thin Augustus
Gloop to a young Clive Owen
Emma Watson
Matthew Lewis is not the only Harry Potter
alum to improve with age.
Emma Watson endeared audiences when she was
barely hitting double digits as Hermione Granger.
Who doesn’t love Hermione with her know-it-all
attitude and courageous sensibility?
Watson was a sweet kid with a mess of hair
that seemed to have weighed more that she
did.
Growing up in front of the eyes of audiences
as Hermione, it was quite obvious she was
becoming a beauty.
Her career has taken off post-Potter with
The Bling Ring, and as Sam, the girl everyone
wishes they knew in High School from The Perks
of Being a Wallflower.
Along with some roles in smaller films, she
is proving to be a rare kind of Disney gorgeous
who is portraying Belle in 2017’s live action
Beauty and the Beast.
Emma Watson went from being a cute kid to
a super-hot adult who totally put a love spell
on audiences.
Zac Efron Zac Efron has always been popular
with the kiddie set.
He may have been a teen dream to ten year-olds
back when he was playing a popular basketball
player in Disney’s High School Musical,
but for the rest of us, he was a goofy looking
kid with a terrible haircut.
A decade later, Efron grew up to be the kind
of hot that all ages can agree upon.
Along with a smoking body, Efron learned how
to dress, and commit to a more classic hairstyle.
After his stint with Disney, Efron attempted
more serious roles.
The Lucky One established his position as
a romantic lead as he played a devastatingly
handsome Marine who comes to a small town
with a secret.
More recently, Zac showed off his sexy sense
of humor in movies like Neighbors and Bad
Grandpa.
The newest progression of Zac Efron is definitely
the hottest and when comparing it to his Bieber-hair
sporting former version, the improvement is
substantial.
Shia Labeouf
Shia Labeouf has gone off the rails a bit
in the last few years, but it is hard to deny
that the man got hot.
He spent his early years as the wacky younger
brother Louis Stevens on Disney Channel’s
Even Stevens.
His nerdy look slowly improved once he began
making films, especially with starring roles
in Disturbia and the massively budgeted Transformers
films.
Along with becoming a bigger name in Hollywood,
he hooked up with quite a list of stunning
celebrities including Carey Mulligan and Isabel
Lucas.
Shia also admitted what many assumed to be
true that he had a fling with the insanely
hot Megan Fox.
The fact that he has had such an odd public
persona in recent years that included public
brawls and unnecessary instances of plagiarism
still hasn’t detracted from his hotness.
His odd performance art pieces and career
choices are enough for even James Franco to
suggest he simmer down his antics.
With all of the craziness that has stemmed
from his career, Labeouf still managed to
go from giant dork to hot weirdo.
Emma Roberts
Emma Roberts is another actor who has been
known to have a screw loose in her real life,
but luckily her equally insane characters
have leveled out her hotness.
Starting out as a child actor on the Nickelodeon
show Unfabulous, Roberts was known more for
having a famous father and an aunt who is
one of the biggest movie stars ever.
She had a lot to live up to and in her early
years she seemed to have inherited only the
long-limbed gawkiness of Julia Roberts.
After playing one of the psychotic killers
in Scream 4, Roberts found her niche in playing
characters who were truly bonkers.
In American Horror Story: Coven she was bewitching
and in Scream Queens she was a batty, yet
hilarious sorority leader.
Emma Roberts is off the charts on the Crazy/Hot
scale, something that is only slightly unexpected
from a former Nancy Drew.
Demi Lovato Recalling Demi Lovato back when
she was a ten year-old on Barney and Friends,
it is proof positive that some things improve
with age The once pudgy best friend of Selena
Gomez has grown into a hot singer and actress.
As a teenager, she rocked out with the Jonas
brothers in the Disney original film Camp
Rock, already exhibiting a more improved appearance.
In the last few years she has evolved into
a confident and sexy performer.
Lovato went through a few personal struggles
that ended up in the spotlight but none of
that matters today.
She went from a nerdy kid whose best friend
was a giant imaginary dinosaur to being a
Demi Goddess.
What do you think of our list?
Who is your favorite nerdy child actor who
grew up to be hot?
Let us know in the comments.
Don’t forget to subscribe to the Screen
Rant channel to see more videos like this
one